foreign
let's go out to Lake City Florida and
talk to the Great and Powerful lore and
what's up Lauren
yes hi Dr John what are you I'm good how
are you
I am great great I can't complain yes
you could but then you'd be like Kelly
so who wants that
what's up true
so I need your help got it um I have the
situation with my mother and I have not
heard this address on your show before I
did some Googling didn't come across it
and I apologize if you've addressed it
but anyway all right not every show is
made up on the Google so it's all good
what's up
so
so Mom is
intake online relationship with a very
famous
actor and director and it's been going
on for a few months now
and she doesn't believe me or anyone
else who she's talked to we're trying to
convince her she's being scammed and is
this famous actor and director asking
her for money
yes how did you know
because very you can even I bet you can
even guess in what form oh jeez
it's so it gets a little funny at first
no it's heartbreaking it's very tragic
these things happen a lot and terrible
lonely elderly folks just get taken for
everything
it's truly devastating
um
how old is your mom
she's 71. 1 okay are you on her she has
been are you on her accounts is this
like a power of attorney
no okay
[Music]
and here's what I'm thinking I'm
wondering about an end around
and this is somewhat deceptive and I'm
okay with it
um sitting down and having a
conversation not about her boyfriend and
not about the person she's in love with
or all that but hey you're 71 is she is
she single by the way
yes okay is your dad still alive he pass
away
okay
um just making sure hey something
happens to you just want to make sure
um
make sure that you're safe make sure
that I've got access to your accounts
that I could
get you the treatment that you needed or
the care that you needed
right my sister I have a sister that
lives in the same state with my mom so
she is on okay she does have access to
her accounts and things like that so
she's been trying to like watch and make
sure that you know mother hasn't given
money away and all this but we have
tried the power of attorney talk before
and she hasn't really been super open to
that yet
she's a very stubborn woman
as we walk as we want our moms to be
except when they're giving famous actors
money right
um
here's the hard thing man I think this
is the hardest thing in the world to do
outside of
physical or sexual abuse
is watching a loved one somebody we care
deeply deeply about make decisions that
we know are actively harming them
and it's very very hard
um I'm sitting here thinking of can you
reach out to William Moore's agency or
CAA or one of these places and see and
let them know
hey here's some emails here's some
Facebook exchanges somebody's scamming
my moms or something you could do
yeah so I even reported it to Facebook
because
Facebook Facebook
they don't care they want to shut down
mask videos and anti-vaxxers yeah
um so I I
I mean maybe appeal to the their agent
you're probably not going to get
anywhere there
um
um the only other thing I could think of
is finding somebody in your community
that you are in that community and maybe
your sister could help a police officer
who would make a call to your mom or
come visit your mom
yeah so we tried that too actually one
of one of my nieces has a friend in town
same town
um and
he shared that there had been a case
where this person was out like a quarter
million dollars and there was literally
nothing they could do because it's not
illegal to convince somebody to give you
money no no not until they I'm saying
yeah have the police officer go to your
mom
right and say Hey I want to let you know
somebody's been impersonating famous
actor and Director X and asking people
for money it is a legitimate scam
and is taking advantage of people and I
just want to warn you about it yeah
maybe
somebody shows up in a uniform maybe
that's the thing
but the draw worth a shot the draw will
be so powerful
yeah and there's she's lined us and
manipulating her grandkids oh she's in
love she's in love with somebody special
and
you so much information is accessible
online now the people can find out
everything about everybody
I know and so
she could ask a hard question and this
person could Google and answer it
exactly right so I mean
you can't fight
you can't logically fight an illogical
person
right
and she is so caught up in love and in
feeling special and feeling seen by
somebody that she deems important that
it's overriding everything it's a drug
yeah
yeah similar to somebody who's
struggling with alcohol who stopped
showing up to family things abandons
their kids or somebody struggling with
heroin or opiates just abandons
everybody
it's not a it's not a rational move but
you're not dealing with somebody who's
seeing the world as it is you're seeing
somebody seeing the world through a
glass Darkly right you can't see it
and she's been through so much yeah so
much and she's always given and given
and given to all of her kids and her
grandkids and her great-grandkids
Predators love a giver
oh it's terrible it's terrible listen
there's literally outside of making a
police report which I think you should
do I think you should call the police
make a formal police report
and see if you can find somebody who's
will show up in a uniform to your 71
year old mom's house and sit down and
have a conversation and say this is an
active scam going on we just want you to
be aware of it opposite of that
I think you get with your sister and
maybe your sister goes and talks to the
bank and shows them some printouts of
some of these conversations and say my
70 year old mother 71 year old mother is
actively in the middle of being taken
advantage of is there anything I can do
there's probably not but it's worth the
conversation
and it might be since your sister's
power of attorney that I mean not part
of attorney but she's on the accounts
every time there's a a a an expensive
500 sent via venmo she gets in there
cancels cancels the transaction as fast
as possible maybe she puts a notice on
her phone that every time there's a
transaction she gets a notice of it
foreign
she just cancels the transaction
but at the end of the day
there's no law there is law against
fraud and there's law against theft but
there's no law against your mom choosing
to spend her money
against the well-meaning wisdom of
everybody who loves her
and that's so heartbreaking
because she's going to give a credit
card number or she's gonna give over the
VIN number to her car she's going to
give a social security number
and that's going to be a mess for
everybody
but famous actors and famous directors
don't need money from common folks
most of the time
I'm so sorry going through this Lauren
the pool of fantasy is going to be tough
at some point get as loud as you
possibly can
be as clear as you can
and then just tell your mom I'll hold
your hand through this they're all a
Devastation and heartbreak and it's
coming
I'm so so sorry Lauren